There's something to be said for optimism.
But the problem about irrational and uninformed
optimism about the Corona virus is that it
encourages people to engage in risky behavior.
And when you believe the crap, Trump says,
you are more likely to engage in risky behavior.
Donald Trump yesterday, during a purely propagandistic
roundtable with business CEOs, was asked a
really good question.
Do you think without a vaccine, we could reopen
to 100 percent?
That's a that's a very good question.
Trump's answers were, as usual, indirect.
They were incomplete.
But at one point, Trump pulls this idea out.
He thinks the virus might just go away.
It's just going to get up and leave like an
angry ex-girlfriend or something like that.
Take a look at what Trump said yesterday.
Without a vaccine, sir, why do you think the
virus will just be gone?
It's good relief.
It's going to be gone.
It's going to be eradicated.
And it might take longer.
It might be in smaller sections.
It'll be it won't be what we had.
And we also learned a lot.
Again, if you have a flare up in a certain
area, if you have a I call them burning embers.
Boom, we put it out.
We know how to put it out now.
So when we do these, Trump said something
crazy stories.
I want to take them as an opportunity to spread
information of value and substance.
So let's discuss this.
Is it hypothetically possible that a virus
just goes away?
It's hypothetical.
Yes, it's hypothetically possible.
If you maintain lockdowns and you get to zero
new cases.
And I don't mean zero new official cases.
I mean really zero new cases.
No one is transmitting the disease, whether
they're asymptomatic or mildly symptomatic.
You really maintain the lockdowns longtime.
You could eradicate this particular corona
virus without a vaccine.
You could also see diminished viral spread.
Imagine that the heat really effects it.
We don't we think if the weather will play
a role, it'll be a small role.
But imagine that this thing, it just can't
spread when it's summer.
It could reduce the ah, not very dramatically.
And you would start to see the virus go away,
but that takes a really long time.
In New York, supposedly right now has reduced
ah, not to zero point seven, five.
Anything below one means cases are diminishing
at are not zero point seventy five.
I read it could take something like five years
for the cases to go to zero.
So hypothetically, the virus can just go away.
No evidence that a corona virus would do that.
If we went back to normal, even slowing the
spread with lockdowns could take a long time
to get to zero cases.
Now, the other side of this is that it could
come back bigger in the fall with the flu
season.
It could kill millions of people.
And that's what you have to prepare for.
So if you think there's a point, 5 percent
chance it goes away and an 85 percent chance
it comes back bigger in the fall, you've got
to prepare for the false scenario.
Now, there are people talking about herd immunity.
Let's.
Talk about that New York City antibody tests
said 21 percent of the city has had the virus
and has antibodies, assuming that having the
virus creates protective antibodies, which
is a reasonable thing to to imagine.
Although they're still gathering evidence
on that.
20 percent is not enough for herd immunity.
Consider that a tiny portion of New York City
has gotten symptomatic versions of the virus
and it pushed health care resources to the
limit.
The way herd immunity works is if enough people
are immune.
The virus can circulate, but the are not goes
very, very low because a lot of people are
immune.
They can't get it.
You could become immune by having the virus
and fighting it off.
You could become immune.
Through a vaccine, depending on how contagious
the disease is, the immunity threshold for
herd immunity is higher or lower.
Example, mumps is really contagious.
It has an ah, not of 10 to 12 very, very high.
So for herd immunity with mumps, you need
92 percent immunity.
That's a lot.
Measles is super contagious.
It has an R, not a 15 to 18.
That's why it's important everybody be vaccinated
from measles.
The corona virus or not is somewhere between
2 and 2.2 is what they think right now.
So women are not around, too.
You need 70 percent immunity for herd immunity.
We don't have a vaccine, meaning 70 percent
of the population gets the virus to achieve
herd immunity.
That implies 1 to 2 million deaths from the
virus itself.
And of course, since 10 percent of people
need to go to the hospital and be hospitalized.
That would so overwhelm the medical system
that more people would die because they were
unable to get treatment for whatever is afflicting
them.
So to do herd immunity without a vaccine could
take years and it could lead to millions of
deaths.
Bottom line, Trump is clueless as usual, but
there are things we can learn from what he
says about herd immunity, about viral spread,
and about how contagious different conditions
are.